[Applause]
donovan mitchell understands the
assignment he's going to run this
shotgun down
as far as he possibly can before he goes
one on one or brings rudy gobert out to
a pick-and-roll situation here goes
mitchell up against her and
did he walk jonas has it and loose stuff
now you got to go
it'll be devante for a win yes
yes
a second left
1.3 put on the clock and a timeout
now we talked about understanding your
guys right how many times have we talked
about devante graham's ability to run
get his feet set and then raise up
they stop that clock in a hurry
1.3 to play officially they'll advance
it with the timeout devonta did this in
charlotte off the bench right there
he's got to bounce to his game he likes
that moment that's right go back again
48 hours ago against the washington
wizards in that same exact spot devonte
graham knocked down back-to-back threes
just like this
in transition excellent recognition by
brandon ingram and trust to know that
this is what devonte graham does on time
on target
and that was a walk to begin with
the illness they actually could have
caught a foul one
from behind on mitchell and devonte
getting rid of it running to fill the
lane bi hitting him right back on time
on target